hi my name is Lambert ow the senior
technical lead for connected devices
my name's kill mark Lee I'm also on the
connected devices team at Wolfram
research we'd like to invite you to
listen to our talk how to stream data
from your connected device in this talk
we'll show you how to acquire data from
your device via polling and abet models
how to build visualizations also talk
about data management and state
management for graphical user interfaces
what we're going to do here is this is
in a way a little bit of a quick
practical example we're gonna go for
broad strokes here about how to stream
data from any sort of device and the
device world will show a couple examples
and we'll carry it through mostly from
beginning to end one of them will be how
the you know in a way how current image
might work the other would be how an
audio capture function might work so
first off we'll talk about ways to get
data into that Mac so there's a couple
ways you could do it you could pull for
data and we'll use the camera as an
example or you can sort of do an event
model which will make use of these
things called asynchronous tasks which
aren't very advertised it's more of an
internal function but you'll get a peek
at how that works we'll try to dive a
little into below lab OC code just
enough to give you an example of an idea
of how you might do that the ideas that
you would sort of go off on your own
figure it out we'll have a basic example
to sort of get you started and then
we'll sort of I'll introduce a bit of
the an internal API of audio capture and
don't get too excited it won't work on
the builds you have this is only on our
internal code but that's a sort of a
peek of what's coming for audio and then
so Caleb will have taken over next and
sort of carry you through from how to
come down API for capturing audio and
put it together it is you know a lot
more to do even though you can get data
and you got to manage the data you got
to control the state of the stream you
get a visualize you gotta have a GUI now
if you want more detail technical detail
I suggest you take a look at our tech
conference talk from last year how to
connect your device to the Wolfram
language and it's actually online in the
screencast with notebooks and production
and sample code that will run on all
platforms so take a close look bear so
but here's the technical low-level stuff
you're going oh he's glossing over all
that look here I was set up in fact I
used some of the code we got from there
as well already so let's start off just
jump right in I mean
so here what I'm going to talk about the
polling model where you keep asking
repeatedly for new data to do that
you're going to be able to start to
gathering one data point we're going to
use the camera and so sort of we're just
gonna this is more stuff than you know
you so you see it's works nothing up our
sleeves but it's you're you're less
interested in exactly what's happening
here broad strokes only so this is using
open CV but j-link wrapper version the
Java wrapper so we're using some great
link code here sitting in this
particular location on my computer and
this is actually available from if you
go to that link I just showed you so
then I create an open camera function
that's really just initialize things you
see there's nothing glamorous here I'm
loading some class path so I can get to
this Java class loaded I open I set some
you know some whips and and Heights and
so forth then we need our core function
to grab frames so we just you know the
camera cap here it gives us back an
array of data and we wrap it in an image
and you know put it in our duties be
space so open camera but light comes on
in front of me here you guys can't see
that and there we go grab frame so we
have you know an image working that's
the first step we have one image so now
we go to whoops I don't know why I hit
that button now we go towards morally
you know and are we there yet motto you
know that kid in the back there is you
know back seat of your car doing are we
there yet are we there yet are we there
yet so you keep asking for data and
there's a function called scheduled
tasks in that matica so you can run
scheduled tasks here and basically it
says you know this expert just keeps it
getting evaluated in various models
well what use to do is we'll keep
evaluating it 12 times a second so
basically I start my camera stream here
and as as simple as you know my single
frame I grab it I store it in a dollar
sign current image variable and you know
comma how many times a second or you
know how often
Peet's well I wanted to repeat 1/12 of a
second to find my Start screen function
and then there's you know an API for
removing the task so you don't keep
going and you also I want to clean up
after myself so I close the java code
the job instance or whatever
so I'd apply my stop function and now I
can start the stream and visualizing is
as simple as putting dollar sign
currently I'm entering a dynamic there
we go okay so then you stop the stream
and as simple as that so that in a gist
is sort of how current image could work
and so it's as simple as if you can
write some code that's the graph more in
function no matter what device you want
an instrument or an Arduino or something
you can easily use a polling model and
one scheduled task to sort of start
looping through and getting data for you
so that's pretty straightforward and
pretty natural sort of just asked for it
when you want it and you start caring
about how often you get it and how
reliable that is so that's one way to do
it it's a little tedious and you know it
really depends on your ability to if you
care about how often the data comes back
in a reliable periodic manner it really
depends on the ability to if you know if
you keep nothing I could busy you might
be stuck doing and integrate it might
not ask for the data at the right time
it might be a little off do you care
about that jitter so now there's a thing
called Neal there's this model called an
event model which is sort of said
wouldn't it be nice if say I had some
it's about trust right so I say I know
these events are gonna happen data could
arrive or the camera could break or
something else
you know and I set up a event in advance
I have somebody I trust and I say well
if and when a event a happens data
arrives then evaluate this callback
function it's called a callback function
because you think of it as you're diving
into the low-level code you're stuck in
there and some Fred Handel
you know all the data coming at you and
every time you have a data you call back
into Mathematica and say here's the data
okay so you know this is a bit of you
know some of these maybe you may be
familiar with this but for some of you
this might be less less you know
familiar paradigm for programming
because you're so used to procedural you
don't know when it's gonna happen
basically you have somebody you trust
and I say hey Caleb when this happens
can you just hand it to me in an
appropriate container and I'll deal with
it and then you can set up you know
these are called vents and you can set
up a few of them so it's about
designating a callback function so how
do we do that in Mathematica well as I
hinted to as alluded to before there's a
asynchronous tasks API so asynchronous
means it doesn't block right it's
happening in the background and it
raises a what's coming event in the
callback function and I'll deal with it
when I can but it doesn't block my
ability in the background to keep
handling the data whereas if if I'm
polling one other whatever I'm doing
it's blocking me and I can't do the next
thing so that's what's called
asynchronous not synchronous as in
blocking but asynchronous so just
roughly will go into exact details here
but we'll have a create a synchronous
task function it's you have to worry too
much about it you have basically it's
wrapping a low-level C library link C
function we'll show you an example if
there was some arguments that you might
want to give it to set up and then you
register a callback function this
callback function it's a mathematical
function that gets evaluated whenever
data comes back and it returns in the
asynchronous tasks object and of course
you have functions to start stop and
remove it so stop in here there's some
you know unglamorous set up here but
let's look a bit at the C code so you
know but we'll just look at the
important functions here you can look at
the other talk to see how to deal with
library link but basically you start
your simulated input stream is like open
camera you do some pre ambling you get
some data
here I'm interested in the dimensions of
the data I want which is you know the
sampling rate how often how frequently
my data comes back and sort of how many
samples I have but the core of it is I
have to tell Mathematica I want to
create an asynchronous task with red
which means if you guys are familiar
with see Fred coding you know I don't
have to deal with pre Fred's or
something that mecha will take care of
that the Seco part of Mathematica all I
do is register what's called this
callback function push simulated data
which I'll show you in a sec and then
argument that ima need the callback
function is pretty straightforward but
it's also where everything happens
so it's just something that once you
call you launch the Fred it just keeps
running in the background and this while
loop while this asynchronous task is
alive so as long as I have not called
remove asynchronous tasks this will keep
going and all you do is nothing
simple it's pretty straightforward you
just create an EM tensor which is on
that matica container for an array and
then I just feel it with random data in
the for loop and then I created what's
called a datastore about the
asynchronous task data container to
serve it back to Mathematica I add in
that M tensor I created so that's my
payload and then I raise the async
events and I throw it back into
Mathematica and once Mathematica gets it
it will call that top level call that
function where I can do fancy stuff and
you'll see what happens there so just
I'm not gonna go through this but you
know you can use if you're familiar with
the C compiler driver you can just
create this compile and create this
binary in the back I've already done
that here so now so that's sort of a
low-level stuff how do you put it all
together here I load the library
functions nothing glamorous here and
then basically and all its telling me is
it's in this library C library and this
is the function just that C function I
wanted to load some arguments which was
just the dimensions
the frequency and then what I'm
expecting back which is the an ID number
for the asynchronous task but you see it
change the callback function there and
that's done using stored current data
and then so you see when I actually
create the asynchronous task I start to
simulate the input stream which is a
mathematical library function now that's
wrapping the C function my arguments are
here and store current data is my
callback function which all I did was
take the payload event data and put it
in the dolls and current data value so
now you can see like you know before
there was nothing no a second is tasks I
create the asynchronous tasks there's
one there and I can start a dynamic and
that just shows me all this line plot of
the random data coming back so this is
random data generating the C code
nothing exciting here but this gives you
an idea what happens next when we go to
the audio capture code of course I can
stop it I can restart it I can remove it
and once I remove it there are no
asynchronous tasks left
okay so capturing audio now this is sort
of wrapped its internal code but
basically it's pretty much the same
thing instead of a random number
generator I'm calling the operating
system you know we use audio cube OS X
API to grab data so first lock I find my
built-in microphone I create a similar
asynchronous task with the input device
I want I designate my callback function
what Chris says store it in the for
variable current audio of the raw data
and you know here's my dynamic node data
to bring back but once I hit start focus
you see this is the live stream of audio
data that's being captured and coming
back to me so now we can go ahead and
you know stop it removing and so forth
but this gets us in the ballpark and so
there's a lot more to do but data is
coming back at you but you got
be able to handle it and deal with it
control it so Caleb will start next and
show you how to you know various states
to take it from this raw API you can
sort of say it's a given to you and then
go into creating what looks like the
audio GUI that you see in a new
functionality we built
blue pissed
all right thanks Lambert all right so
now that we've gone through all that now
what what do you do when you have access
to the data from your device
there's obviously any number of
different things you could do but we'll
be focusing on some common ones data
management functionality and design
state management and visualization
throughout the rest of this talk we'll
be looking at specific ways to implement
these things and we'll be focusing on
fairly straightforward approaches you'll
probably see redundancies and other
opportunities for optimization but those
are included for the sake of clarity so
let's look at data storage first here
are three straightforward approaches to
data storage in the Wolfram language one
is appending elements to a list one is
adding key value pairs to an association
and finally editing a pre-allocated
buffer which in this case is also a list
the idea here is we're streaming data
constantly so we want to be adding data
to our chosen container also
continuously so let's look at each
option the first option is using a list
and append - this is probably the
simplest option and the most familiar
it's easily growable and we can check
out the performance here I've got my
data and I'm just appending that data to
a list it seems reasonable at least at
first glance so let's let's take a look
at Association next if you're not
familiar with Association and the
Wolfram language it's essentially a map
each element contains a key which then
maps to a value this is also easily
growable and note but a one thing to
take note of here is that the
performance is considerably better so
finally we have a pre allocated buffer
we initialize a list with zeros then
simply change those values as we go so
this is actually going to be the fastest
method as you might expect but not not
that much faster than Association this
implementation however is not grobel
if you were to use one that were if you
were to modify this and just say like a
ring buffer it certainly could be
growable but in that case it adds
additional complexity that you may or
may not want to deal with so you'll have
to decide for yourself which of these or
any other method makes the most sense
for your purposes for our purposes
streaming audio data as it's happening
is performance sensitive so we probably
want to avoid just appending to a list
since the Association buffer options
have similar performance we'll go with
the simpler approach for this talk
additionally it also has the added
benefit of making individual buffers of
data more easily accessible for our
visualizations so next we're going to
talk about we've talked about data
management so we're talking about our
actual data management symbols so we've
decided on our storage method let's
figure out what we need to keep track of
audio input data will be our Association
that's used to store the audio data when
we have data to store we'll add it to
audio input data using associate to with
audio index as the key when we finish
streaming our data will consolidate our
data and store that in the symbol audio
data again we're keeping it pretty
simple here so let's let's look at one
of the actual functions we're going to
use to build this this structure this is
our reset function all we're doing is
taking our data management variables
initializing them as well as setting the
audio tasks to none so for clarity data
management early as symbols will be
highlighted in pink and streaming or
related symbols will be highlighted in
blue those will probably look familiar
from Lambert's previous slides so let's
talk about functionality and design next
let's talk about our goals we want to
record live audio we want to visualize
live audio during recording we want to
be able to pause the recording and we
also want to stop the recording and
consolidate our recorded data so let's
go ahead and take a look at the finished
product here before we continue to dive
through
the implementation so you can see we
have an area in the GUI for the
visualization a button for starting a
button for starting the audio recording
you can also press that to pause it we
can record let's record some more and
then finally we can press stop to finish
and then export to dollar-sign audio
data we can then do something so we we
know our data is now in audio data we
could create an audio object we want to
rescale our data a button for starting
the audio recording and then we have
that yeah so there that this talk isn't
focused on GUI particulars there's a lot
of other good talks happening today and
tomorrow on that but we'll go through
what we have here mainly for the
purposes of state management
visualization and as well as data
management ok
so we'll talk about state management
next if you're not familiar with the
concept of state it's essentially a
certain configuration of values that
information in our case Wolfram language
symbols have at a given time so at any
given time we could be recording audio
we could have recording paused or we
could not be recording at all which will
be our stopped state so we've got two
symbols here started which will be true
when recording or when paused and then
we also have and as false when when
recording is stopped we also have the
symbol recording which is true when
recording false when posture stopped so
our three states we have recording when
both are true paused when recording is
then false and then stopped when they're
both false if we are able to reach some
state where started is false and
recording is true we're gonna have we're
gonna have some problems
so this is our initialization function
we've talked about our state let's get
that set up
so first we've got our stream related
symbols we have device which will be the
built-in microphone found via audio
device discover we set our sample rate
our samples which are the number of
samples we're capturing in each buffer
next we have the callback function this
looks a little bit similar to one of
Lambert's previous slides the callback
for current image so in this case it's
pretty simple we associate the data
accessible by the callback through this
data parameter here we associate that to
audio input data using the key audio
index and then we increment audio index
yeah so pretty straightforward then we
have our state we have started recording
we initialize those both the false and
those state related variables are going
to be highlighted in green finally we
have some other symbols at the bottom
and gray texts they related to
visualisation in graphical assets for
the GUI now they're gonna be highly
dependent on your design choices they
weren't strictly relevant for this talk
so we don't really spend much time
talking about those when you see gray
text okay so we've gone through our data
and state management symbols let's start
diving into the rest of the code to make
this the Scooby so live audio is our
sorry capture audio is a top-level user
facing function we saw before it calls
our initialization function and then it
calls GUI which is below the GUI
function is simply a grid the first row
contains the visualization the second
row contains dynamic of our record
function the only argument there is our
recording our state variable recording
and then also stop so next let's so
let's go ahead and look at record stop
and fizz so we'll start with record the
argument we pass in from GUI is
recording so this so for this down value
used this is when we have not started
yet record is just a button
it's how its label is a graphic asset
when pressed if we're starting a new
recording will call reset to reset our
data management variables will then
create a new asynchronous task with our
stream relays symbols defined in the
initialization function
so all these should look familiar and
you will recognize run so this run audio
capture asynchronous task is an internal
function similar to what Lambert showed
before we are you start your
asynchronous task so this will begin
streaming data from the microphone and
each time there are callback which we've
passed in as a parameter here every time
that is called it will store the data we
then set both recording and started to
true and we can see if we just put a
frame around that what this is so next
let's look at our pausing the recording
so this is our down value for when we've
already started recording when the
button is pressed we stop streaming of
data by stopping and removing the
asynchronous task we'll also go ahead
and clear our audio tasks just to be
safe and then finally our state needs to
be set to pause started is already true
so we just said recording the false
we've got this guy as well so finally
we'll talk about stop when stop is
pressed we want to stop streaming this
is very similar to the pause button we
also want to clear our audio tasks let's
see
and since we're okay so we also want to
consolidate our data for you say in an
audio object or something like that so
go ahead and combine all the recorded
audio data together and store it in
audio data and since we're back to our
stop state we set recording and started
to false alright so the last thing to
cover here is the visualization as
stated before
it's obviously gonna be dependent on
what your goals are what data you're
collecting for example when Lambert was
showing current image the visualization
was just dynamic of current image
however we'll go ahead and go through
how are visualizing the audio data in
this GUI to give an example of a way to
use each buffer of stream data
individually as opposed to using it all
at once like when we're creating an
audio object from that captured data
okay so if we are currently recording we
want to grab the previously recorded
data buffer from audio input data if
we're not recording or if there's some
error accessing that data in audio input
data we'll just use an array of zeros
there a list of zeros to give a flat
line in the visualization so once we
have our data we turn that into data
points that can be usable by a graphics
object which will then draw that
waveform so we've we've gone through
pretty much all we needed to create that
audio capture or capture audio and you
want to do the conclusion okay do you
want to show the payoff again there's no
yeah yeah sure why are you showing that
yeah so basically you've seen the you
know a couple ways models of how to get
data again the remind you polling or at
that wise and you see sort of how we can
deal with how we can manage it and and
so forth the next slide and then so you
know remind you again scheduled tasks
and they stick in this house for you to
deal with it and then now hopefully you
can sort of take this basic caricature
and sort of apply it to your device so
you're gonna remind you to take a look
at our talk from last year if you wanted
more technical details finally some
interesting talks I wanted to make sure
you guys are aware of we have three
audio talks tomorrow related to this and
also go down to the connected devices
playground and we have a bunch of these
things set up and you can we can talk
and war death and you can play with some
of those stuff we have an assertive
skunk works with yes
[Music]
you mean what came up did well it's a
global container right the asynchronous
task so so are you talking about a fixed
spot for it yeah the fixed buffer for
that particular example we we have a
fixed size that's as if that's for like
an example where you know exactly how
much data you're gonna read and you're
not you know you're not going to eat any
more than that right if you're gonna do
something else right so so his case
actually was not exactly what we were
talking about here so suppose you did
audio capture of three three seconds you
know how big it is
but it's coming back to get half second
intermix but that's where it gets
challenging right because when he was
talking about ring buffer that means he
you can mod it and sort of loop it back
but then you know you lose data when you
loop back and it becomes a bit of a
hassle but yeah so yeah so a few ways to
deal with it yeah yes yeah well that's a
very good question so we do a lot of
that in the C code like you know we in
the way a lot of the heavy lifting was
done in that library Lang stuff there
you have you know see new Texas
Mathematica if you're familiar it's a
single evaluator and use cooperatively
pre-emptive right so basically you'll be
doing say in and Esau and then you'll
preempt and say hey I want to deal with
this data that's coming in so there's a
function called preamp protect and what
you try to do is sort of anything where
you're accessing something you would
want to mutex up you try to use pretty
up to protect to think about loosely as
trying to make that operation a bit
atomic say yeah pretty unprotect you
want to be careful when you use it it's
a bit of a heavy mouth dynamic sort of a
high-wire balancing act so so sometimes
you could easily lock things up so it's
it that's where a lot of the challenge
can be yes
the list is um so basically a listing is
a turns it into a expression in
Mathematica it's a very heavy struct
there's a lot of metadata around it so
every time you append to your actual
Erie copying all the stuff there and
expanding it every time you generate a
new expression so it doesn't scale well
so you keep growing it at the
Association is sort of more designed to
be you know growable and assertable so
sure you can throw you know inch with
symbols with whatever you know it's more
geared toward symbolic but we're here
we're dealing with high performance data
management so yeah yes
sure yeah so in the dynamic of dollar
sign current image you can have a
function there that sort of does image
processing and then there's a Sunday or
something or if you were doing the
asynchronous tasks one where I have to
call that function there you can sort of
you know poke it into your callback
function and the second one is a bit
more
it doesn't require dynamic so you can
the evaluator has a bit more time
dynamic again and sort of more
performance demanding also requires that
the dynamic be visible when it otherwise
it doesn't update it's trying to
conserve power
okay Chris do we have our next speaker
in here okay yeah I think you should
wrap up please feel free to find us
after the talk